pourquoi t'as fait ça qu'est ce que j'ai
fait pour que tu fasses à la
confrontation et déjà au fond du trou et
l'huile a juste rajouté une pelletée
dessus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
qui a été un formidable puisqu'il a fait
venir anna avec sa fille ana qui était
en ukraine il ya une amie elle aussi qui
va venir la semaine prochaine je sais
quoi que vous dormez dans le sur le
canapé du salon ce monde et ça voilà bon
ça va ça va je connais bien mon canapé
bamba très bien ses olives et c'est vous
qui l'avait proposé c'est son ami qui
était un ami elle qui est à donner ce
qui est ukrainien dont qui aujourd'hui
se bat non son pays qui lui a dit on est
en train de voir arriver les premières
bombes il faut olivier alors pouce est
venu aussi aujourd'hui parce qu'on a
tous vu la photo et sur les réseaux
sociaux je leur ai dit aux
téléspectateurs
ça a été un déferlement oui ils
accueillent anna parce que c'est une
belle fille voilà donc et c'est vrai que
ce soit olivier je tiens à le dire il
est très courageux et il voulut il a dit
moi je réponds à toutes les questions je
mette fin à ces polémiques parce
qu'olivier il fait pas du tout ça pour
ça et s'il faut qu'ils accueillent
d'autres gens il accueillera d'autres
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il est en train
de faire dans les prochaines semaines
mais gilles allain poser une question
que serré que c'est la question qui se
pose sur les réseaux sociaux pour leur
poser à hollywood les vielles autour de
la vulnérabilité de ces femmes seules ou
avec des enfants qui arrivent et on se
pose tous la question quelle est la
réelle motivation qui vous fait
l'accueillir et
[Musique]
moi je trouve que là ça c'est pas mon
père non mais c'est pas ça le truc c'est
parce qu'elles sont c'est ce que est ce
que voulait c'était une amie à elle
c'était une amie lui c'est pas il la
connaît pas depuis juste js que vous
espérez initie une relation avec elle
voilà quel est le vrai but qu'est ce que
moi j'espère quelque chose de ça moi je
n'espérais simplement une chose c'était
aider une amie lui donne un objectif à
atteindre pour qu'elle se sente bien
aujourd'hui je pense qu'elle se sent
mieux de là à dire qu'elle se sente bien
c'est pas le cas c'est pas le cas parce
qu'effectivement elle a de la famille
des amis des amis qui se battent etc etc
c'est la guerre elle se sentir bien on
ne peut pas baser une de toute façon
enfin je crois pas un mois pas dans mon
monde à moi une relation sur ce genre de
choses nous est impossible il ya un an
vacants agir
oui je voudrais dire quelque chose a
terriblement choqué
c'est vrai que j'ai pas une tête que
réfugiés mais j'en suis sûr
3 millions de femmes à 20 nous avons
appelé au secours comment appeler à
l'aide
parce que j'ai joué
des photos pierre
j'ai vu que l'on plaisante-elle à son
sujet
certains commentateurs
permettait
de faire des
commentaires qu'ils ont faits concernant
l' avantage d'avoir des réfugiés de
jolis réfugiés j'étais terriblement
sauter moi au départ ça m'a fait sourire
au départ ça m'a fait sourire c'est
quand j'ai compris derrière ce qu'il y
avait dedans dessous c'est à dire tous
ses jambes envoyez moi j'en veux cette
chez pas si c'est lui qui a commencé 7,7
ce comics la ctu maurice tu la mets déjà
bon il utilise ma photo comme photo de
profil donc moi je me réserve quand même
le droit de simplement de l'attaquer en
justice pour usurpation d'identité ça me
fait sourire mais je vais faire comme ça
parce que je pense qu'il faut lui donner
une petite leçon il ya moi j'ai
simplement accueilli parce que c'est une
amie j'espère qu'elle ira bien et
surtout j'espère qu'elle pourra
retourner chez elle bien sûr parce que
c'est ça l'idée hélas le sait parce
qu'on en parle de temps en temps je n'en
suis pas certain voilà je n'en suis pas
certain j'espère que ça se passera bien
voilà je ne sais pas quels pays elle va
retrouver qu'elle apprécie si elle
rentre et c'est moi je lui ai aussi dit
que ma porte et est ouvert ma porte
personnel était ouverte à toute sa
famille et à tous ses amis peu importe
si on doit être une dizaine dedans c'est
pas le problème voilà on est sûrs a de
la place
d'hier marine le pen je vais voter pour
elle parce que c'est une gentille maman
elle a des petits chatons tout mignon
dernier alors que la production de fort
boyard a décidé de conserver son rôle
dans l'émission peu importe ses opinions
matthieu delormeau s'en est offusqué la
dame blanche et une aide et à vue elle
joue mais pur
il est même allé plus loin en comparant
directement delphine à l'humoriste
dieudonné condamné plusieurs fois pour
l'incitation à la haine et pour
discrimination raciale
alors mathieu est il allé trop loin avec
delphine ce soir elle lui répond en
exclusivité dans tpm je pense que ça n'a
étonné personne non mais c'est bien pour
ça que ça pas fait beaucoup de bosses en
a été donnée personnes
le dire mathieu c'est le poison incarner
je pense qu'il va y avoir un vrai mal
être en lui pour diffuser autant plus qu
autour de lui
jetez pas étonné parce que mathieu rêve
d'être comédien alors que c'est
peut-être d'ici ce fait si je me fais
virer il peut prendre ma place ça se
trouve la perruque bleue ça lui va très
bien mais manque de pot je suis pas
virer donc les seuils pour l'année
prochaine enfin voila je ne sais pas
quoi de dire je trouve ça tellement au
sort tu me fais pitié en fait
il ya deux choses que tu aimes tu es pas
vraiment d'admission de bain
des choses regarde même pas elle a pris
en grippe l'argent qui t'aime toi même
j'ai contacté des avocats donc je peux
porter plainte contre x pour diffamation
et injures pu me prendre l'oseille en
plus
alors ce sera fini du terrain ce n'est
pas ce que
ça l'a blessé mathieu dieudonné fins et
c'est un comparatif que tu ne peux pas
faire c'est vraiment le coeur du sujet
c'est de comparer à dieudonné en fait tu
ne fait que renforcer l'idée que les
gens qui votent extrême droite quand il
est confiant tous des fous bams à quel
moment il ya eu comparaison comme cela
que l'on meilleure comparaison elles
peuvent être aussi dieudonné dans une
émission a calé
non c'est pas les joints sont les mots
la division à mettre des gens qui ont
dépensé à mon sens extrême comme elle ne
l'avait pensé que si vous répondez tout
seul à la réponse extrême je tenais je
lui dis que je ne le droit de concèze
qui serait horaires donc son père et sa
mère pour le renard attend dans les
salles à la défense les moyens mais en
les faisant passer
les mathieu il allait plus en passer
pour des monstres tu ne fait que
renforcer mais cyril je m'arrêter là
parce que tu es beau tu fais ce qu'il te
ma mère qui n'est qui n'est plus là j'ai
du poison en moi je suis une merde je le
pense aussi qu'on sait qu'il ya un petit
débat de fond j'ai décidé de
m'arrêter là j'ai eu plus de bas avec
toi ça va ça fait bizarre où est basé le
vendrai pas ma mère et je sais plus ce
que dédain ça va s'arrêter là et du
poison et je sais pas moi je m'arrêter
là delphi moi tellement méchant je
m'arrêter votre pourquoi coup tellement
méchant à bâle avec les autres à
balamand alors sur le vois je pensais
qu'on discutera à peu du fond j'ai du
poison je suis une merde je veux être
comédien je vendrai ma mère qui est
morte dans les six mois à m'arrêter là
voilà mon histoire ok effectivement tu
lui dénie le droit d'avoir une réflexion
il a le droit de penser que tu n'avais
tu ne peux pas être sur fort boyard ce
n'est pas ce que je pense mais s'il a
dit que la tendance est à
la carte c'est delphine de tous les
dames c'est toi qui en a c'est pas moi
ma seule pensée c'était qu' il n'y a pas
il nous donne ne doit pas mettre de
politique dans fort boyard point bas
touché quelqu'un qui avait de
l'affection ou qu'ils avaient un minimum
de respect ne m'aurait jamais comparer à
dieudonné vendredi soir quand j'étais
chez moi en train de pleurer devant ma
télé et en a rajouté une couche pourquoi
t'as fait ça qu'est ce que j'ai fait
pour que tu fasses ça honnêtement
d'affiner je pense pas que ce soit
contre toi je pense que ça aurait pu
être quelqu'un d'autre c'est que mathieu
aussi je me permets mais mathieu a une
façon un petit peu provocante aussi de
dire les choses et de manager je me suis
dit heureusement briser un très bon
producteur mais là il est allé trop loin
non mais je te tue regrette d'avoir fait
débat c'est pas ma nature
je réponds pas
le
cadre des débats en effet à millas avec
cyril mais je vais tout donner sur mes
amis et tous démarré et on va tout
donner mais temarii un débat avec du
poison pas quelqu'un porte que mathieu
n'a pas de poison ici il veut mon pays
de mon métier il vendrait sa mère il a
commencé avec man fin d'histoire et
franchement je sais que j'ai pas bon
très souvent quitté le plateau je le
quitte pas par politesse mais je me tais
terminé donc ne me pose pas de questions
tu parles de poison de machin d'évoquer
une image à l'épinglé tout autre image
ap tandis que quand tu me lance comme ça
eh bien eh ben ça reste pas sur le net
et de ta besoin de moi pour te faire une
image on est sur le débat d'idées car
ici on est sur la confrontation et la
guerre on y trouvait lui la juste
rajouter une pelletée dessus mais pensez
aux idées lancées au cjb moi je vous ai
défendu le droit d'exprimer vos aînés et
jugé que ça aide va tu as le droit aussi
de s'exprimer là là vous êtes en train
d'établir une chanson infernale et
arrêter de penser que c'est contre vous
delphine c'est contre ce que vous avez
dit
et un règlement de compte par écran
interposé celui de simon castaldi
candidats de télé-réalité et d'hervé
patrons de bars à chicha en vendée
dommage de poserait pas contre toi mec
est malhonnête
en toi ton père ton grand père tu ta
famille jetons
alors qu'il avait bouclé les
influenceurs pour une soirée samedi
dernier simon castaldi aurait empoché
l'argent sans jamais se présenter on se
donne rendez vous le samedi 27 pourquoi
il n'est pas venu à la soirée non
m'aider à partir du vendredi
plus de réponses
plus de réponses ok nous on a tout
acheté un nom s'est cassé le plus on a
fait la bouffe on en avait pris les
réservations on a tout fait samedi pas
de nouvelles et on l'appelle on
l'appelle j'ai envoyé tous les messages
j'ai scanné tous les messages j'ai fait
tout j'ai tout fait ok on sentait la
carotte les gens nous appellent en
lisant ben simon vient de faire une
vidéo il paraît que sa meuf 6h10 y
en a tant là vous avez fait une vidéo
ensuite pour vous plaindre ouais c'est
dans la salle ça s'énerve et du
comportement de simon parce qu'il ya des
gens qui sont venus quand réservé que
pour sont venus exprès pour voir si moi
je vous ai fait là d'abord s'appelle
insulter des gens publiquement moi et
mon père traiter sa mère de plus tout ça
ça je vous dis franchement ça ne se fait
pas monsieur je ne fais pas après les
relances les messages que j'ai sur mon
téléphone vous le menacer c'est quoi ces
façons de faire vous créez ou à février
passant de fermeture à
17 points tu m'insultes mais toi tu
redescends je m'en fout de toi déjà pour
commencer et déjà je vais vous dire à
rester ici c'est aujourd'hui votre fils
il fait les marchés est furax et grâce à
qui c'est quand son public c'est pas
grave famille qu'est ce que quand les
gens quoi vous mettez dans la sauce
encore mais deux importants mais des
modes à la sauce genou mais pour envoyer
mon père de sa mère et qui c'est quoi le
rapport il faut qu'on trouve le moyen
pour le court et le moyen de vendre a vu
que tout est fait sur les réseaux de
légende tels sont nos téléphones
portables insulté sa mère mon père et
moi je n'y suis pour rien monsieur on se
connaît non je vous ai escroqué non je
vous ai manqué de respect non elle
pourrait vous le faites vous insulter
mon père sa mère et moi ça s'appelle ça
va assure public comme ça je vais porter
plainte ensuite vous le menacer et vous
menacez donc je vais reporté parce qu'il
est maintenant vous allez arrêter de
poids de penser qu'elle a nos socios
c'est un déversoir à merde var et qu'on
peut tout dire toulouse avant la loi
monsieur votre fille jouer leur message
je suis pas mon fils et fils qui joue à
ma gueule à ses quatre fils qui m'a fait
génial quoi la liane là je m'en fous
question je m'en fou qu'est ce tu
racontes là c'est tout l'art est de nous
faire chier et ont fait insulter l'islam
arabe qu'elle coûtait alors j'écoute pas
je ne suis pas prêt d soit ni mon père
ni moi ni sa mère attention tu ne manque
pas de lui payer ni à moi ni à poupet
revient à sa mère je crois et je crois
que l'argent il me semble il semble
qu'il a rendus à cet après midi d'une
foi qui est le feu est-ce qu'il a rendu
cet après-midi ce qui l'a rendu cet
après midi est ce qui la rende oui ou
non cet après midi là ok bon je me suis
fait chier dessus j'ai rien fait mon
père est celui ci dessus il arrêterait
sa mère retraite de [ __ ] c'est pas grave
l'histoire est réglé et on se fait de la
pub on vient il d'annoncer sa mère m'a
insulté sur ce plateau et c'est ça se
comporter en tant que le mal qui touche
ne pas avoir je peux avoir des alertes
google et mes potes qui habille qu'est
ce qui s'est passé ton fils avoir des
messages d'insultés moi sur mon
téléphone en disant des agriers monsieur
est dérisoire du songe à une femme moi
j'ai moi j'ai que ses quatre enfants
j'ai pas envie de me sied dans les
bottes pour une sorte de boîte de nuit
dont le moral est bon marché mais on n'a
pas le droit on n'a pas le droit de
faire en sorte que la haine se déchaîne
sur les autres et parce que monsieur ça
a des conséquences et un jour je vous le
dis faites pas fait ça si vous voulez
mais un jour quand il y aura un drame
quand on aura quelqu'un qui sera qui
sera qui sera frappé ou qui sera but et
on viendra sur le plateau pour pleurer
parce qu'ils étaient buté et ce sera
trop tard monsieur monsieur sera trop
tard chez castel bayard eu un drame ce
sera de retard je n'ai plus rien à vous
dire je vous souhaite bon courage avec
avec votre désir je veux que vous le
souhaitez voir que c'est vrai fils mais
moi j'ai rien initiative mais très bien
que seulement et seulement 6 fautes
c'est lui benjamin lagarde et jean simon
free et alice et peut-être qu'il a
peut-être qu'ils avaient tort mais si
mon fils ils font pas mal taillé pour un
coup de barre à mine et que je le
retrouve mort dans la rue parce que vous
avez décroché là elle est moins de leur
gloire
[Musique]
totalement folle on y voit slate le fils
de 6 ans de kim et du rappeur kanye west
jouer avec l'ipad familial quand soudain
un
sac si oui il tombe sur une publicité
pour la sextape de sa maman et la
starlette de fondre en larmes au
téléphone avec cannes et
c'est pas très drôle mais quand même un
peu un avoué
alors ces choses oui chez désolé on va
pas pleurer pour elle c'est les limites
de l'argent facile en fait c'est ça
qu'il faut dire à tous les jeunes
aujourd'hui qui sont tentés de vendre
des contenus dénudée a forcément des
sextapes y en a plein à tard elle ne le
fait pas parce que les images elles
restent et les gens sont certes on
trouve jamais la mélasse et remet à
temps plein et c'est que c'était
totalement commerciaux de débuter sa
mère qui arrivaient tout ça il y en a
dix qui
vient tapent leur étoile ben non mais ça
c'est pas les y découvre pas s'exprimer
bons services au fond je peux te le dire
et
moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est qu'en fait
de guillaume dit oui mais là tu
t'adresses aux jeunes il faut pas je
suis désolé mais c'est hyper tentant de
faire une sextape de l'unirc une
carnation et déjà posée
les aventures donc et non mes photos il
y avait des photos de quoi
mériter notre foi nous a demandé s'il y
avait des polars c'est vrai
j'avais des photos
[Rires]
t'as quoi avec un mec connu
personnellement
connu mais non mais attendez vous je
suis bon je vais
imprimer dans le magasin et tout mais on
a une chambre noire pour les autres
images non mais ça je sais pas ça mais
qu'ils en aient occupé donc là enfin
c'est pas vrai quoi si riche et
[Rires]
ça c'est toi sur le balcon
c'est fou ça rigolait away mais j'avais
j'avais 19 ans 20 ouais quand même
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]